حسنًا، إنها بعد الساعة السابعة مساءً في المغرب، حيث
يواصل المستجيبون الأوائل الحفر
بين الأنقاض بحثًا عن ناجين
بعد الزلزال المدمر الذي وقع يوم الجمعة،
ويقترب عدد القتلى الآن من 3000 شخص،
ومن المتوقع أن يرتفع هذا العدد بشكل مأساوي، فقد
دمرت آلاف المنازل ونزحت العائلات CNN
يقع سام كايلي في قرية في شمال
المغرب فقدت نصف سكانها البالغ عددهم 200 نسمة،
وهذا هو ما تبقى من القرية
الصعبة الآن وتمتد البلدية
إلى أعلى التلال حيث لا
يمكن الوصول إليها إلا سيرًا على الأقدام هنا في
المنطقة الوسطى حيث كان هناك 200 منزل.
الآن في جميع أنحاء المنطقة قُتل حوالي 88 شخصًا
وأصيب عدد أكبر بالطبع
لأنه في الساعة 11 صباحًا ليلة الجمعة،
هذا ما حدث،
وهي مشاهد مماثلة في كل قرية
على كل تلة في هذه المنطقة في
سفوح جبال الأطلس، كما
لو أن  تم ختم عملاق يركض إلى أسفل التل، لقد
سحقت الحياة مستقبل
سكان هذه القرى، والآن
هناك نفحة في الهواء
ليس من الجثث ولكن من الحيوانات الميتة
وبالطبع الحيوانات التي
تمثل مجتمعًا زراعيًا مثل
هذا
الدخل في الوقت الحاضر، والمعاشات التقاعدية
للمستقبل، وفي الواقع أي نوع من
الأمل في التعليم المستقبلي للأجيال
الشابة، لقد تحدثنا الآن
إلى الناس هنا ويصرون على أن
بعضهم يريدون أن يكونوا قادرين على
إعادة البناء ولكن من  من
وجهة نظر الحكومة، يتعين عليهم الذهاب مباشرة
إلى تلك الجبال إلى
المناطق الأبعد بكثير باستخدام
طائرات الهليكوبتر لإسقاط المساعدات مع
الكلاب البوليسية لمحاولة معرفة ذلك في هذه
اللحظات القليلة الأخيرة المحتملة للعثور على
ناجين تحت هذا النوع من الأنقاض
في محاولة  لتحديد الحاجة الأكبر
وسيكون ذلك
نشاطًا مستمرًا ومحفوفًا بالمخاطر، ومن ثم بالطبع
يتعين على المغرب بطريقة ما استعادة
سام كايلي سي إن إن في تركات